[ APPLAUSE ]
♪♪♪
>> GOOD MORNING, MR. TRUMP.
>> HUGE, HUGE SUCCESS.
FANTASTIC.
VICTORY, LANDSLIDE, FOX NEWS.
>> IN FASHION BIG LOOSE SUITS
AND LONG RED TIES, BIG
SUCCESS --
♪♪♪
>> MR. TRUMP.
>> TRUMP.
>> THANK YOU SO MUCH.
TRUMP IS BAD.
TRUMP IS LIES.
TRUMP CAN'T DO ANYTHING.
>> LOSER.
EVERYONE HATES YOU NOW.
LOSER.
>> I LOVE YOU, DONALD.
I'M A LUCKY WOMAN.
I'M BEAUTIFUL FOR YOU.
I AM LUCKY WOMAN.
>> MIKE PENCE HERE.
WORK JOB, DUTY, FOCUS, OTHER
PEOPLE.
OTHER PEOPLE NOT TRUMP.
SO MANY PEOPLE.
>> IT'S KELLYANNE, YOUR FAN
WANTS TO MEET YOU.
TALK TO YOUR FAN.
>> I VOTED FOR TRUMP.
YOU WILL FIX ME.
YOU PROMISE.
THAT THING YOU PROMISED.
CAN'T WAIT FOR THAT THING YOU
PROMISED.
HOLLYWOOD MODELS ARE NOT YOUR
PEOPLE.
I AM YOUR PEOPLE.
>> COME, COME.
KELLYANNE WILL FIX IT.
MOMMY DOES EVERYTHING.
MOMMY LIVES FOR YOU.
SLEEP NOW.
SLEEP AND DREAM.
FAVORITE DREAM.
♪♪♪
>> I LOVE YOU.